Carlos tercero es oficialmente el nuevo
rey ha Jurado ha firmado su acta de
proclamación También es importante se
presentarán ustedes por qué tantas
firmas bueno Carlos también ha Jurado
lealtad y defender la fe de la iglesia
de Escocia El Monarca es el jefe de la
iglesia anglicana de Inglaterra y
también el jefe de la iglesia de Escocia
Así que en este momento Carlos III es
oficialmente el nuevo rey y en pocos
minutos veremos que delegados de este
consejo de Ascensión saldrán al balcón
del Palacio de San James Para
comunicarle al público que hay un nuevo
rey el Rey Carlos III Santiago que ha
Jurado lealtad y continuar con el legado
de su madre y creo que la gran reflexión
la clave del discurso del Rey ha sido
ese continuidad
los votos de su madre Isabel segunda
quien estuvo en el trono 70 años y siete
meses ha renovado esos votos será rey y
estará dedicado al servicio hasta el
último suspiro de su vida e inicia
oficialmente entonces una nueva era aquí
en el Reino Unido podremos ver también
que inmediatamente con la noticia de el
nuevo rey las banderas de las
residencias oficiales y de todas las
instituciones públicas británicas y en
territorios o versis podremos ver la
bandera del Reino Unido y los emblemas
de la monarquía podremos ver las
banderas ondeando a toda hasta porque
desde la muerte de la reina han estado a
media hasta en señal de respeto pero por
24 horas estarán de esta manera estamos
presenciando como lo mencionas un
momento histórico Santiago sin duda
Puede que haya simpatía o no por la
monarquía pero sin duda estamos siendo
testigos de la historia por primera vez
podremos ver tenerlos detalles de
primera mano poder ver las expresiones
toda esta tradición que se ha mantenido
por siglos En este país y ahora el Rey
Carlos III ha abierto las puertas al
público hemos podido presenciar este
momento histórico si me permites el rey
ya tiene unas audiencias confirmadas
serán en el Palacio de buckingham esta
tarde se reunirá a las 2 de la tarde con
el arzobispo de canterbury que es el
líder de la iglesia anglicana después
recibirá a la primera ministra a las
2:30 de la tarde y al gabinete en el
Palacio de buckingham un momento bien
importante también a las tres el rey
recibirá los líder de los líderes de los
partidos de la oposición que son por
ejemplo el laborista que es el partido
más grande en oposición el partido
escocés que quiere la independencia del
Reino Unido y a las 4 de la tarde el rey
recibirá al decano de Westminster Así
que una agenda agitada pero lo que
veremos en los próximos minutos que es
un momento viene motivo seguramente será
cuando los líderes del Consejo de
Ascensión salgan a leer esa proclamación
que hemos visto que ha firmado el Rey
Carlos III su hijo William el nuevo
príncipe de gales que es El Heredero al
Trono y su esposa Camila que es la reina
consorte entonces saldrán estos
delegados del Consejo no sabemos si el
rey también saldrá van a leer esto y
Entonces será la manera como el público
se enterará siguiendo la tradición de
que hay un nuevo rey Así que una mañana
bien emotivo hasta ahora Santiago y allí
Estará presente por supuesto Franz 24 en
español